what it is it's Tyrus and welcome to the
black Zone edition of
Gutfeld I don't have a reason for that
other than I really like my fort
so now and of course since I've set up
the black Zone I can now start the show
five minutes
late that's a black joke not allowed to
laugh
now we're now we're nice and
uncomfortable all right let's go well
Christmas has come and gone faster than
a biological male beating a woman in a
track
meet and I'm sure everyone got lots of
presents except this
guy you know little Butterfield invented
the naughty list so wherever he is I'm
sure Santa's Bells did not wake him up
all right now I'm sure we all got
something would like to return to the
store but remember even though it's a
big screw you to whomever gave you the
present apparently it's not all about
the thought that counts and of course
you shouldn't feel bad for wanting to
exchange it for something
better which brings me to my monologue
tonight I want to remember all the crap
We As Americans received in 2023 that we
wish we could send back
for starters you all have the lump of
coal that Hollywood turned out this year
yeah Hollywood had its worst year in a
generation which means the movies
sucked more people walked out of movies
this year than Dad's going for
cigarettes in the
1970s mine's not back
yet
I love the one person who fights the me
like the sad joke thank you Mom all
right which is sadder I haven't seen
that many misses since Kennedy took up
softball not
good not good you can laugh at me not
having a dad but making a joke about
Kenedy not playing softball just sco too
much all right because
in so many of the movies that bomb the
woke nonsense was the key ingredient and
they all all they cooked up with box
office poison and speaking of
woke ask budl how smooth that woke stuff
went
down hey even Spud McKenzie wouldn't
hump that leg you know what I'm
saying that was for you
Kennedy so my advice when it comes to
gifts keep it simple stay on target okay
maybe not
Target they clearly also missed the Mark
or thought Mark was more of a
[Music]
Diane and some gifts just plain royally
suck and you need to send them back
where they came
from oh yeah we we we taking shots
tonight we throwing Shots tonight now
I'm not a complainer swear I'm not
I usually just keep my aunt's pink bunny
suit and just
regift like good old juicy small a he's
the gift nobody wanted but just keeps
coming back you know like the fruit cake
that makes you
puke what Everyone likes fruit cake too
so no Kennedy and stay off fruit cake
okay although he lost his appeal a few
weeks ago and is likely headed back to
jail at least there he won't be attacked
by anyone wearing a Maga hat
and speaking of people that were full of
this year gave us a lot of them George
Santos Sam bankman freed also known as
Dumb and
Dumber they lied their way to the top
speaking of which we had Equity hires
who refused to condemn anti-Semitism by
the way rup Paul called he wants his
glasses
[Laughter]
back
just look at
that I'm when you're right you're right
now we had the squad and pretty much
anything they said all year we had the
scammers from BLM maybe we should offer
them a free trip to Canada I'm sure
they'll love it there in the winter
there's tons of racism to rot it out in
the polar bear
Community but some sometimes we get a
surprise gift that just doesn't
deliver kind of like the surprise
balloon party China was throwing for us
until someone in Montana peaked up at
the sky remember
that and did you hear the latest the
Biden Administration plan to keep the
Spy balloon a secret from the
public what was the president trying to
do save taxpayers money on not shooting
it down
if old corn poop really wanted to shoot
something down he should have shot down
the idea of making taxpayers pay back
everyone's student
loans now the court said no but Biden
thinks anyone in a black robe is well
the angel of
death you know because he's
close
yeah and no one wants that gift either
kind of like Mike Pence running for
president and while I have you all here
speaking of white
people what the hell happened to y'all
in
2023 like I'm I'm trying to understand
this classic white people got fed up in
Europe grabbed some oranges hopped in a
boat fought through the rough Seas
fought in the snow fought at night to
get here then you got together you wrote
Constitution classic white people kicked
ass and took names and a couple other
things which is how I ended up here but
it's not
important but this new version of white
people in
2023 now a bag of oatmeal with blue hair
and a pronoun name tag scares the out of
you what happened to white people get it
together and I'm not just saying that to
just yell at you because runs downhill
and under mount white Bliss is
Blackville which means we're next and
I'm saying Hell no we're not getting
woked out in the middle of nowhere just
like poor juicy
did but the biggest buyers remorse this
Christmas drum roll
Kennedy that's right old cord pop Biden
ended his third year in the O in the
opal office with the worst let's get it
again the worst approval of any
modernday
president which is quite a fee for
someone who died in
1970 so we we don't always get what we
wish for but I'm pretty sure nobody was
wishing for another four of sleepy Joe
Biden except maybe Juju
ping
#n all right
let's welcome tonight's guest he worked
for the NYPD back when they still
arrested criminals former New York
Police Department inspector PA
Maro she packs more heat than a suitcase
full of Duraflame Town hall.com editor
and Fox News contributor Katie
pav she's more fun than losing your
virginity host of Kennedy Saves the
World podcast
Kennedy he was the intellectual savior
of the masses and the king of kicking
asses somebody wrote that for you wasn't
me actor pro wrestler and co-host of
Tyrus and the wisan podcast the one and
only Aaron
Hadad
welcome Paul I I'll go to you first you
will huh if oh I have to uh first of all
thank you for your service what you've
done in law enforcement returns if there
was something I missed on my list what
was something you would love to give
back I think you caught it all um I that
was first of all great monologue
terrific you caught it all um it was a
great year it wasn't a terrible year I'm
going to tell you by a couple of reasons
first of all Hollywood this was the year
of the great pushback and sincerely
Hollywood traditionally is how America
talks to the world and since like the
1960s or so the message to the rest of
this planet has been America is terrible
you go overseas you hear that from
people and that's not what we should be
doing this year we finally CED on to the
fact that number one we don't
necessarily need you and over the next
few years thanks to AI we're not even
going to need actors they'll just
generate them you can generate them with
a with a computer which means we won't
anymore have to listen to Katy Perry
tell us how to vote we won't have to
listen to Mark rufalo tell us what
horrible people we are because we're not
voting for progressives so I actually
think this is a very significant uh year
for that reason alone we're finally
seeing the push back against La La Land
and you know what let them talk to each
other we don't need you anymore speaking
of push back you you've seen it all and
you've been outspoken you've been on the
woke anti-walk front froms day one are
you seeing a switch are we starting to
get somewhere close back to the middle I
think you're saying great competition in
this experiment we call capitalism you
see new movie studios popping up people
big in Hollywood who have been
blacklisted not because they didn't make
hundreds of millions of dollars for
people but because they are conservative
or libertarian leaning going to
different companies and producing big
films now there might be more work to do
but that certainly is happening and I
think that Hollywood has been putting
this plug andplay plotline into every
single thing they make and it's just
boring like I don't even think obviously
has to do with wokeism but it's just
boring you you know what the story is
going to be about so why would you waste
your time paying money to go go to
something that's be inappropriate for
your kids or whatever or spending time
on Netflix when there's so many
different options so yeah I do think
that there there is a turnaround and
this show has been a huge success as a
result of the competition as well this
this is true Erin you're a allegedly an
actor you're out there you just had a
you did a Netflix special it's pretty
funny uh the the what was it the Pay It
Forward the Pay It Forward thing does
this concern you at all the fact that
apparently we no longer need you because
AI you're you're done well that's why
I'm here I mean you know trying to uh
diversify a little bit but I think in
Hollywood you know what we've seen in
the last several years was especially
with the Hollywood Executives they are
plating to the needs and ideology of a
few as opposed to creating art for
everybody and uh that really it's kind
of I think reached the point now where
the pocketbook is being affected and
that's why we're starting to see the
turnaround well you know and that's why
you go out and you get wrestlers ladies
and gentlemen that is exactly why I was
a little worried but man you just nailed
it yeah you may call you may applaud him
you may applaud him thank you
well timy you have been the host or the
co-host of this Wild Planet on camera
behind the camera for I won't say more
than a decade because we got to protect
it's since the early 1930s 1930s you
you've been there you've seen it all yes
life is Trends is are we starting to
come full circle I think we are coming
full circle and I think people are
getting sick of it because people want
to go to movies but they really don't
want to be lectured to because movies
are supposed to make you feel something
it is about escapism and you can't feel
anything when you're being told that
you're a horrible person or that your
worldview is a flawed one and you would
think for every Bud Light there would be
a course correction but you know now you
have Modelo coming in going hey man our
our beer tastes like piss too so we
might as well have people drink that
more than anything else but people
people wanted to see top gun Maverick
and you know it's like it flew in the
face of well you can't just keep
Reinventing franchises it's like if you
write something great that people are
emotionally connected to and you have
the added benefit where people actually
feel really good about this country
maybe they will go see it and you know
they they made two interesting totally
contrasted movies Barbie and Oppenheimer
that made people think and feel but that
was not enough to save the industry
because you had way too much money being
poured into utter crap like the Marvels
and I would like to take that and give
it I would like to take Disney back give
Disney back this year just I don't even
think Florida wants it anymore no no and
don't forget Godzilla subser was
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal but
before we go reminder that my new book
well I just happen to have it with me
not said is now is available now in
stores of course on Amazon or Barnes &
nobl and all plac you find bestselling
New York Times books but uh don't forget
to pick up your copy I have mine hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else